les oscars de l'automobile les prix des
véhicules de l'année moment fort du
salon de l'auto tout comme lé lancement
en grande pompe des modèles 2010 9 mai à
détroit présent et futur de l'automobile
se côtoient ici on sue chasser le volet
mobile idée d comme d'hab des trois
voitures autonomes véhicules
intelligents moyens transports futuriste
c'est le rendez vous des amateurs de
technologie
impossible d'ignorer les entreprises
québécoises et ontariennes et britanno
colombienne qui occupe une place de
choix sentimental rogers est née quand
on a constaté au moment de la fondation
la compagnie est certain que les
systèmes de détection de collision sont
offerts dans les automobiles
présentement au des endroits où ils
fonctionnent peau donc ce qu'on veut
c'est améliorer la fiabilité plus un
obstacle approche plus le niveau d
alerte augmente technologie que
l'entreprise de québec espère
commercialiser d'ici quatre ans se
servir aux mobiles électrique assistée
et tu pédales aussi alors ses as tu
pédales et sa reçoit de l'énergie du
moteur électrique
une invention vancouvéroise déjà en
service à l'université de colombie
britannique
une nouvelle forme de mobilité urbaine
qui attire les curieux c'est qu'on a
c'est de faire une formation de notre
tête technologie parce qu'on a beaucoup
de bonnes technologies on a beaucoup de
talent mais les personnes et sa pop
opération charme donc pour attirer les
investisseurs et retenir les créateurs
au canada il n'y a pas que les petites
entreprises de chez nous à detroit
blackberry se lance dans l'automobile
plus précisément dans la cyber sécurité
à l'ère des véhicules intelligents mais
la li na est primordiale pour l'avenir
de l'industrie automobile et la
commercialisation de ces nouvelles
technologies lance le ministre benz
ils rencontrent d'ailleurs les
dirigeants des constructeurs automobiles
cette semaine pour en discuter ici
philippe leblanc du cad à detroit